Jim how would you recap what you saw
last night from start to finish
interesting you know coming in I think
we knew what to expect coming to a
strong military town you knew there was
going to be some backlash against Colin
but there also were a number of
supporters for Colin you know in the
stands a number of 49er fans what I
found most interesting is that in
talking to players and coaches from both
teams just how much support was really
there for him I mean I knew having
talked to some players prior to that but
once you got there and you were able to
look guys in the eye and really feel and
since you know their feelings about the
situation I was really struck by it and
and you know 149 player in particular
told me that if he had known Colin was
going to make this silent protest you
know initially that he would have taken
a knee with them or sat with him so I
think that's the thing that they're
outsiders and the noise wants to say
this is a distraction and what teams
going to put up with this and i can tell
you then across the league players
firmly support colin in terms of the
message he's trying to get out there
they might not necessarily agree with
the method but they definitely support
the message how did he perform I thought
he performed okay I mean the first drive
was important from the standpoint of
look he hasn't played good football for
several years now and in fact the last
few he's been regressing you could make
the case and he had a terrible preseason
game you know prior to this one and so
to go out in a hostile environment where
he knew so much attention was going to
be focused on him and to take them down
the field on the opening drive overcome
a couple of penalties and put them in
the end zone that was big now you know
you can say he was playing against
backups and we weren't game planning but
he also was playing with backups so from
that standpoint you can make the case
that the field was somewhat level but
you know it's going to be interesting to
me the next couple of days because
already I'm hearing this talk well now
the 49ers have to keep them the reality
is he wasn't going anywhere
based on this if Chip Kelly came out
earlier in the week and said he's one of
our two best quarterbacks so if the
49ers had released him by Saturday then
they would have given off the perception
that this was a political action instead
of a football decision and that's what
I'm saying to you I couldn't see any way
that he was going to be released going
into week one I still don't see it the
question I would want to ask him if I'm
Chip Kelly is what are you are you a
social activist moonlighting as a
quarterback or are you a quarterback
moonlighting as a social activist can
you do not I think Colin answered that
last night where he essentially said you
know they don't have to be mutually
exclusive he said I spent 12 hours a day
at the facility with my teammates with
my coaches and meetings and everything
else and once I leave their what I do on
my own time is my time so if you're
asking him I think he's going to tell
you he can do both and I find it
fascinating when people say well why now
as if there's some sort of timetable for
when young men have social awakenings
and if you talk to Colin again if you if
you look in his eyes and talk to people
around them there is the real sense that
this is very genuine and he is now he
has come into this at his own time you
know in terms of being socially aware
and wanting to address certain issues so
you know I firmly believe that this is
real that column believes that he can be
an effective quarterback and that he can
also try and and heighten the discussion
about something that he's very
passionate about it and feel serious
about yeah I tried to tell my audience
you know you may not like the message or
how the message is delivered I think
that's what bothers a lot of people but
I said listen to the message first and
we've moved away from what he said
initially and that's what bothered me I
may not like that he is kneeling but I'm
not walking in his shoes I I can only
try to understand what he is
representing or what he's seen or what
he's heard I can't sit here in my you
know lily white Palace and say man how
can you do that discrediting you know
the American flag I think if he had to
frame it different you know frame it
again
frame it a little bit different not
softer but different because I think it
came out that it was against the
military instead of it this is about the
police and that flag is not protecting
me the way it does white America if he
had a mulligan what'd he do it
differently you know I'm not so sure
that he would damn because I asked him
specifically last night I said how
disappointed are you that the further we
get away from people noticing your
initial protests that we've discussed
everything but the message behind your
protest yeah we've discussed your method
we've discussed the national anthem the
history of it the author of it we've
discussed whether or not we should even
have a national anthem and all of a
sudden this is morphed into Colin
doesn't respect the media when in fact
if you go back and you listen to his
initial press conference he never said
anything about the media in terms of
disrespecting it has always been on
point about police brutality you know
systemic police brutality and the
oppression of people of color so it's
funny that people then start to apply
their own beliefs so what the flag means
and everything else and you're right we
get further and further away from the
message and that's why I continue to ask
every day when the story comes up okay
we've talked about all these other
things but when are we actually going to
have a dialogue about his message and
Colin said last night he goes it's a
tough discussion to have and he believes
that's part of the reason that people
aren't talking about it and are talking
about all of these other things his Jim
Trotter covers the NFL for ESPN joining
a Stan Patrick show I mentioned last
hour that DeMarcus Cousins is doing
something and I said right but most of
you don't even know what he's doing and
he went to his home he's going to his
hometown of Mobile Alabama to get
together with the community and the
police defoors to unite and understand
to build trust but nobody's talking
about DeMarcus Cousins doing something
like that why correct because one I
think that again this is a tough
discussion to have and look it's always
easier in my opinion to find fault then
than to get behind something that may
make you a little bit
uncomfortable but it's the right thing
to do so from that standpoint the thing
you know last night Collin said he's
going to donate the first million
dollars of his salary to organizations
that are that are fighting for humanity
and for social justice now I asked them
specifically which organizations are you
talking to right now and he did want to
get into it at that point but the thing
that he said is he goes look I want to
go into communities I want to help I
want to be a part of the solution and
therefore you know I think with that
sort of call to arms by him I think
you're going to see more players I
grilling that yeah and getting out and I
think that I think it's fantastic so you
know ultimately I just I stand back
somewhat and I watch what has been the
reaction to him and how we get
distracted with all of these other
things and then I talked to these
athletes particularly ones last night
who tell me you know you can see this
matters to them because particularly
with the black athlete as they were
saying to me you know look we all know
someone who's been impacted by this if
it hasn't been us you know ourselves and
something needs to be done about it and
I think that the people are looking for
direction on it and it is a tough
discussion to have but I think until I
always say until you can acknowledge
that there is a problem there's really
no reason to have the discussion because
it's not going to go anywhere and so I
think Colin and hopefully some of the
other players around the NFL you know
start to bring this to the forefront in
terms of people actually do sit down and
have discussions about ways to to
correct you know what are some social
and justices second biggest headline
story from the preseason is what oh my
god damn been so tied up on Colin all
week I think probably you could talk
about the Cowboys with romo out and how
is dak Prescott going to play I think
that's big how does the Patriots handle
life without Tom Brady for four weeks
even though I don't think that's such a
big deal I think that they'll be fine
without him during this short spell and
then when he comes back I think they
just hit hit the ground running Teddy
probably often yeah but you know look
nope no doubt that impacts the Vikings
but I think if you're talking about
really the unknown when I look at a team
like Dallas and an NFC East that's wide
open that's what I focus on and then all
of the things behind tom brady being out
and the way that the leak handled it and
people are going to have their feelings
on whether or not it was just or not you
know this is the first season opener
Tom's going to miss since when back in I
can't even remember what year was two
thousand maybe two thousand one I'm not
sure so from that standpoint I think
those would be the two to stand out to
me great stuff Jim thanks for joining us
and safe travels damn thanks for having
me that's Jim Trotter ESPN NFL writer
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience